oh it's been so cold and wet here in
virginia
our family needs to go somewhere dry and
sunny and warm
like portland you ready to go to
portland yeah
all right let's do it
okay tommy you can go to the bathroom
just do not touch
anything okay
few moments later
i told you not to touch anything
luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel and me and my whole family are
here in ariel washington with our great
friends
the south family
[Music]
and for those who don't know ariel
washington is home
of db cooper the infamous hijacker who
in 1971 jumped out of a plane with a
parachute in the dead of night in this
very area
with 200 000 in cash only to
disappear forever so today we're gonna
see
if we can survive in the woods of ariel
washington
with our parachutes you guys ready
yeah yeah let's do this let's do it
so seriously we're gonna go in the woods
here and try to make shelters
and camp and survive in the woods using
1970s era
military parachutes who wants to pull
this thing
i'm a little scared
i'm so scared i dumped my shoes
so apparently there's this little
jack-of-the-box thing that pops out
and it's this little mini parachute
which then goes
and pulls out and unravels the big
parachute
i want to see how big this thing is oh
here she comes on the zipline
[Laughter]
this could be a really bad idea on a
windy day but it's not a windy day
i am so out of shape get set go oh
this is getting hard
in the dead of night november 24th 1971
d.b cooper jumped out of a plane with
200 000
cash and parachutes just like this
and he must have landed somewhere within
a few miles
of where i'm sitting right now so we're
gonna see
if we can use a parachute to survive
in this wet soggy forest
just like bb cooper would have had to if
he survived the jump
all right i think i need to fold up my
parachute and go find a spot to build a
shelter for the night
what an absolutely gorgeous place to
build a shelter
but the family's hungry so i think i
better get a fire going so we can get
lunch for everybody
and then i'm going to start work on our
shelter hey guys will you help me build
a fire
yeah start piling up wood right there
okay guys
everything about this place is wet the
moss is wet the wood is wet it's going
to be
a trick lighting a fire so we got to get
a lot of good
wood out of the east coast i wouldn't
look twice at this piece of wood it's so
wet but i actually think it's going to
be one of our better pieces
when the ground is wet like this you
want standing dead wood so
dead branches that are on the tree trunk
are going to be so much drier than the
stuff on the ground
just got to be careful and not lay it
down on the wet ground
all right check it out i got a big old
cedar tree here this is a cedar tree and
it's just enormous
but uh we can go and get these dry
branches
the best wood is dead and should just
snap off really easy but not be
mushy or rotten
add this to my pile of dry stuff one of
the best parts about cedar trees is
their bark
cedar bark is good for so many things
this bark is great fire starter and it
also can be pulled off in strips and
woven into cloth into mats
and you don't want to take living bark
you want the dead stuff that's peeling
off anyways
all right nice pile
hey guys check out my folding saw agawa
makes this thing
and uh i really like it i've been using
it for about six months now
folds up and folds down really quick
[Music]
protect it
oh yeah
all right we got some firewood whew what
you got there tom
a p a teeny tiny bit of fat wood oh yeah
smell it why did you show me where you
found it we're gonna try to collect the
type of fire starter called fatwood
when you get an evergreen tree that dies
all the sap drains down to the bottom
of the tree trunk and when the trunk
falls over
you've got this stump that's full of
flammable
pine tar and you can chop up bits of
wood that are super saturated in this
flammable
pine tar and use it as a great fire
starter and it's called fat wood the key
to finding fatwood is using your nose
when you chop into the stump you should
be able to smell that pine smell nice
and strong
what do you got there oh yeah
smell that right there it's strong it's
strong i already smell it i can smell it
all the way over here
oh yeah smell that tom the stuff here on
the back is rotten so we're just gonna
take the axe
get rid of that rotten stuff and this
all right here is fat wood
all right got this piece of fat wood
we're gonna see how it burns i'm gonna
make some shavings and give it a go
oh the smell is just amazing
all right i got my little thing of
vaseline here got some cotton balls and
we're gonna
dip those in vaseline
like that pick them apart a little bit
so they catch an ember better
this is the very precise throw
everything on top of the fire technique
make a little pan here
you hungry yeah should we have corn dogs
yeah all right let's make campfire core
dogs
for lunch today let's look for a hot dog
stick
oh that's a good looking hot dog stick
perfect
all right guys we're gonna make campfire
corn dogs and i've got a mason jar full
of the batter here and we're gonna dip
some hot dogs in this and then boil them
in peanut oil
i'll go ahead and put the recipe down in
the video description if you guys want
the details
i made the dough last night it might
have stiffened up on me but let's see
how it's doing
that looks great i think that'll work
see how it's bubbling but not too
aggressively that's just right
right about there that is mine
that's your corndog
oh look at that that is perfect
just stick it in the ground like that
and it can cool off and drip dry and
she'll get nice and crispy
let me let me put some ketchup on it
okay like this
you like it yeah and if push comes to
shove you can take your knife and spread
a little on the hot dog
oh that looks good right there i think
you're perfect man
dump it in there right nice kind of give
it a nice twirl see how it's getting a
little bit violent
we're gonna pull it off yeah we're gonna
pull it off the heat here
watch this all right i can pull it out
for a little bit
let that one sit would you like a cord
dog i would love a corn dog
i'm going to make a corn dog for you
i was like nathan you're rubbing you're
rubbing all my batter off
so my my son nathan is uh pooping in the
woods over here and we forgot to bring
toilet paper so
uh we're gonna we're gonna get some
busch craft toilet paper here
try this moss well nathan liked the moss
and everything seemed to have
worked out okay what do you think of the
moss toilet paper i love it
i'm getting pretty thirsty so i'm going
to boil some water from the creek real
quick
well my pot of water has been boiling
for way long enough
time to go cool it down
that's icy cold water we'll just let
that sit there for about 15 minutes
it'll be nice and refreshing
it's a little bit yellow it has some
floaties in it but it's clean
and cold i think it's time to start
building the shelter and i am going to
need
some dead wood
there we go got myself a ton of paracord
all right there's this hole in the
middle of the parachute i want to close
that up
um well there we go not a bad looking
teepee huh
let's uh take you on inside
it is noticeably warmer in here it's
nice and while this
material isn't exactly waterproof the
steep angle and the tension
should make it drain off to the sides
instead of dripping through the material
plenty of room in here you know
traditionally with teepees they were
built the way they were so that you
could build a fire in the middle
and have the smoke go out the top but i
really don't know
what this material would do if it lit on
fire on accident
it might be really nasty all right let's
go get our gear and start setting up our
beds
is that cool guys hey guys what do you
think is this cool in here hey wait
look at this what'd you guys get you
guys got adventure agent backpacks
and adventure agent badges yeah the
south family
their youtube channel is called the
adventure agents and they go on all
sorts of adventures they have really
cool swag
but fyi we have outdoor boys t-shirts
for sale too i'll put a link down in the
video description
to their stuff and to our new t-shirts
as well
by the way river you're rocking that
outdoor girls t-shirt of ours
looks amazing we need to get off the
ground a little bit so we need
a bunch of moss i want a huge pile of
moss
what do you got there pillows pillows
yeah that'll work as a pillow
yeah it's a little wet but we can dry it
out by the fire
beds and pellets oh that's a big chunk
of stuff
oh it took us let me hit that so guys
why don't you take the moss and put it
in the bottom of the teepee so we can
sleep on it
yeah patrick you never wanted it
man well while the boys are off
gathering moss i'm going to cook dinner
and i'm going to be making some butter
chicken curry oh it's going to be good
[Music]
we got the boiling bag rice here easy
peasy
we're going to supplement our curry with
some forest vegetables and herbs here
and we got one right here we got some
stinging nettle
you guys might recognize this plant is a
very unpleasant plant
to touch but if you grab the leaves from
the top
it can't get you and then once you cook
it it actually is really good and tastes
kind of like spinach
so which is really good in the curry all
right there we go
so this right here is wood sorrel and
it's an edible plant you find all over
in wet places and it
it kind of tastes like rhubarb it's got
a very tart flavor the brown stuff too
so you got some
fiddlehead fern shoots we're gonna need
about 20 of these
do you think you guys can gather enough
fiddlehead ferns and sorrel and stinging
nettle
yeah all right do your thing and bring
the pot back to me okay
okay simplicity factor here we're on the
opposite corner it kind of hits land
further south well check it out this is
all the herbs they got man
that'll go good in the curry there
that'll give us some nice vitamins
time to add some greens
fiddlehead stinking nettle butter
chicken curry
thank you
i don't know if it's just because i'm so
hungry but this curry
is hitting the spot it's delicious
it's doing it for me it's doing it for
me you like that tom oh i love it
you like that oh no we've got to get
things hustling here
i got to get the boys beds made up got
everyone fed and we got to get to bed
plenty of room in here nice
we got the beds all made and now
patrick's telling the boys campfire
stories about db cooper
out and he trapped small game and he ate
whatever
everybody inside tell me lead the way i
see
london i see france i think i'm gonna go
to bed at the same time you guys do oh
the boys zonked out so quickly
they're so tired well i'm gonna get
ready for bed myself and i will see you
guys
in the morning
wow
[Music]
all right we got jacob's socks drying by
the fire here
all right for breakfast we've got steel
cut oatmeal
we've got some madeline's your little
french cookie
that you dip in hot chocolate and to go
on our oatmeal we've got some honey
some heavy whipping cream and some
raspberries all right see
just dunk that in there mmm i wanna see
what it tastes
like without
it work well with my stomach that looks
so cool
yeah okay so so we can
hide yeah all right oatmeal's done just
add a little cream and honey and
uh we're good to go so people can have
seconds
thank you okay well that was amazing but
the raspberry
it's really good it's a lot different
than instant oatmeal it is it is
night and day this is delicious thank
you well breakfast is in our belly and
now we're going to break camp but this
is not the end of our adventures here uh
patrick
has been planning uh some fun stuff for
us to do
and uh we're gonna take you guys along
the ride and give you a little sneak
peek at the video he's gonna be posting
on his youtube channel
all right i found the ultimate
backpacking tool it's called patrick the
sherpa
you're doing great patrick well we got
the campsite all cleaned up and becca's
here with my niece grace and we're gonna
do some fun stuff with the kids
including checking out some lava tubes
hey how'd it go
we're all right
all right guys you ready for a treasure
hunt all right
come on
[Music]
i have here the exclusive first clue
i'll tell you what patrick did a bang-up
job on that treasure hunt if you guys
want to check it out
make sure you watch his video i didn't
want to spoil uh
all the surprises for you guys so i'll
let you guys watch that on your own
oh
all right guys we're doing a little
field trip we're going to the trail of
two forests here
near the ape caves and we're gonna see
some lava tubes
neat
[Music]
we're near mount st helens and about 2
000 years ago it erupted in lava covered
this area
including some very large trees which
burned away
and you can see this tree burned away
and it left a little well-shaped hole
there
you can see where the roots go out that
way here's another lava hole where a
tree used to be
oh check it out there's a ladder all
right i'm going down the ladder
see this is where a couple tree trunks
fell sideways and got burned up
[Music]
hello we just got in wow
so a big tree was on its side when the
lava covered it
all right let's go back
go down this hole where the trunk used
to be and there's all these
crisscrossing tunnels from the logs that
burned up
so this is where the lava tube comes out
river you don't even have to hunt that's
once that's it
oh look at you guys are caving machines
hey tom do you want to go underneath go
back with the camera
here i'm gonna go
[Music]
[Music]
there's just children popping out of the
ground here and see there's these lava
tubes
all over the place there's one there
there's one there there's one there
there's one over there oh guys this was
so much fun thanks for
inviting us out we had the ball coming
thank you
we really appreciate it we had a blast
well guys if you enjoy this sort of
thing
make sure to check out the adventure
agents youtube channel that's the south
family
youtube channel and i'll put a link in
the video description below
and if you guys like these sort of
camping and adventure videos
make sure to check out the outdoor boys
youtube channel and don't forget to
subscribe nailed it
we put out new videos every saturday
morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
here we are at haystack rock cannon
beach
it's where goonies was filmed you want
to go out and enjoy the sunshine
yeah there you go babe okay here we go
is it wet out there it's what i've been
to the oregon coast
it's a bit blustery out there i'm very
cold